l' usage d'un drone est il illégal
l'auteur de cette vidéo a dû payer 1000
dollars d'amendé car il n'avait pas
l'autorisation de faire voler son drone
au québec
de son côté ce groupe de musique
américain a tourné son dit ophir avec un
drone résultat un succès planétaire
bienvenue dans le monde des drones un
monde qui a des règles strictes surtout
au canada
vous voulez faire voler un drone pour le
plaisir pas besoin de permis mais vous
devez être capable de voir l'appareil en
tout temps et ne pas le faire voler près
d'un aéroport ou d'une zone habitée vous
voulez faire voler un drone à des fins
commerciales
il vous faut une autorisation coup mais
tous ne respectent pas les règles
surtout au québec depuis le 1er janvier
transports canada a ouvert 60 9 enquêtes
impliquant des drones dont 36 au québec
d12 amendes qui ont été distribués pour
des vols de drones depuis 2014 toutes
l'ont été au québec
difficile de dire précisément combien de
drones volent illégalement au dessus nos
têtes mais transports canada en détecte
de plus en plus souvent à mesure que
cette technologie se développe notamment
dans l'agriculture la construction la
publicité ou encore dans le secteur de
la musique